[Music]
conspiracy theories have erupted oh my
favorite
over plans to
demolish
the school at the center of the texas
mass shooting oh are those conspiracy
theories what so so the news is the news
is in valdez robb elementary school
where the most recent texas mass
shooting happened
uh they're going to
demolish that school now
too many nasty memories oh so there's a
conspiracy nasty memories that's that's
the uh that's the non-conspiracy
theorist front it's uh much too
traumatic for all the students staff you
know faculty parents and somebody go
there now
i can be reminded on a daily basis so
they have chosen to demolish the school
which has created a large conspiracy
eruption because obviously there's still
an ongoing investigation of different
things there's still a whole lot to
uncover oh yeah
because people are viewing it as a
destroying like of evidence
well i think people are already it's
such a it's such a hot topic right
there's already so much whether you're
you're on like the whole gun control
side to just well it's 99 times the gun
control conversation like we did with
sandy hook like years ago you know what
i mean it's like you always see these
like crisis actors different things like
that um those are just among the
conspiracies that are just coming back
with this type of texas school shooting
um but same thing it's like now if
you're going to just demolish a school
it's like where do you go with that you
know what i'm saying so cause don't you
need like a [ __ ] ton of money to build a
new school yeah is that covered by it
sure is going to be way more juicier
like you know they're trying to build
more condos there
i tried not to laugh at that but it was
so it was so juicy it was so juicy on
the level of conspiracy oh [ __ ] they're
gonna build more condos like i thought
they were gonna be like maybe the school
is on some native american burial ground
no that's not that's just
or like oil condominiums
it's all for profit they're making a
[ __ ] golf course there capitalism is
the biggest conspiracy theory
condos
um but does the town have to vote on and
how does that work so okay realistically
one one of the big things too because
like i said it's always about gun
control right somebody had commented
quick to demolish when the investigation
is still going on i have nothing against
the demolition but not until the
investigation is totally complete to use
this shooting and our empathy as a way
to take away or chip away at our second
amendment is evil just by the fact that
they're using this awful shooting as
their excuse they're taking it down to
build a shooting range are they
conspiracy
uh demolish it like asap yeah why would
pretty much yeah but the police the
police the town could just be like no
there's an active
murder investigation going on and our
kids going to school or is it summer
time they're like it's the summer
demolish it another co another user
commented uh quote they almost always
demolish what they don't want uncovered
somebody else wrote they want to get rid
of the evidence of a setup before it
gets found out
um so what would the setup be just the
negligence
yeah at that point they were saying that
sandy hook didn't happen [ __ ] and then
it was just like yeah what about all the
other schools they didn't demolish all
the other schools polished any building
columbine [ __ ] virginia added a
second story that [ __ ] yeah i don't know
what a [ __ ] sabaro and that's cool
samaras are sick i always wanted a ball
pizza does cute cute pizza calzone pizza
shop in new york
me and
new details have emerged of the police
officer's botched response to the fatal
shooting that's the stuff that i've been
reading about the most not not so much
the whole gun control thing yeah but
more about how they were there within
minutes and they've just been standing
by for 40 minutes there was a video that
they released a couple days ago inside
the school they've been inside 20
minutes after they shot you could see
them with shields they have everything
ready and then they didn't pursue yeah
because the protocol from what i heard
is
it's nationwide whenever there's an
active shooter on the premises it's get
in as soon as possible right so the
chance the police chief told them not to
and i think that's what they're trying
to figure out and there was another
police officer from another city whose
kid goes to that school oh the border
patrol guy yeah he went there and then
they disarmed him and didn't allow him
to save his own kid too so it was just a
lot of crazy
didn't the reason why the shooter got
hit
because of a border patrol guy that went
rogue who's off duty that's what they
say like so then the rogue guy came in
and took him out and did what the police
did not but then like who really knows
every week i feel like there's a whole
other [ __ ] story 100 i mean it's it's
going to be an onion they're going to
keep yeah but it seems like the money at
the time it seems like every story that
you come out is that like how negligent
they were of course yeah i mean none of
those times they just dropped the ball
yeah but then they already [ __ ] made
it clear that they [ __ ] up like their
department's like yeah we here's the
issue it's about accountability right
like what is going to be done so that
this doesn't happen ever again probably
not and the answer is nothing i feel
like that speech happened after every
mass shooting and then 300 more happens
until the next speech there's an easy
answer to this but
i'm sure it'll be really popular more
guns
this is what i say this is what this is
what i don't call centers for if if
tomorrow
if if there was a new law that said
every person of color in america in
accordance with the second amendment
were to get a gun
i guarantee you there'd probably be gun
control
you know what's funny um the only time
that nr the nra
went for gun control was when the black
panthers started to arm themselves in
front of city hall
that was the only time the nra actually
voted for he just backed up that's why
they should just arm all teachers but
i'm actually not for gun control
flamethrowers [ __ ] it guys you give a
[ __ ] morning star maze
but that's that's the only time because
um during that time there was a lot of
like
police brutality going on in oakland
they would pull black dudes up being the
[ __ ] up you know in front of everybody
to make a point right and then the black
panthers were like all right let's just
stand there with rifles and say we have
the right to observe the law and then
the cops stopped beating up random black
guys and then when they did the protest
they would stand in front of the
building with their shotguns just to
protest but at that time open carry was
completely legal like the way people
open carry like in red states like when
they do the protests there's a bunch of
guys york just passed luck today we went
to the supreme court today for open
carry okay or to allow to allow open
carry the written house clause and i'm
like what scratch your head with it
something something like that but then
during that time though when they were
doing that sacramento like the black
panthers were doing that in sacramento
and then the nra was like we can't have
these n-words with guns so then they
started going in and actually lobbying
against uh open carry sounds about right
i was like that's so [ __ ] wild dude
but then now it's like very minority
friendly they're just changed they're
just trying to really have to it's
different dude like because collier noir
is one of the biggest advocates again
right now so like he's black it's so
weird how long but they're small they're
just financially powerful there's like
not a lot of members per se of the nra
yeah there's i think 300 000 or
something and i think some of them too
it's like when you buy a gun in
california or whatever they they ask you
do you want to sign up and they'll be
like sure and it doesn't it doesn't cost
anything or something it's like five
bucks a year or something email list so
some people are probably on the mailing
list and members no and they're yeah so
those stats we don't really know how
powerful the lobby is or whatever i
think i think everybody in the planet
agrees that there should just be normal
common sense gun laws but for some
reason with those donations well first
you need the people with common sense to
follow them but you know what tomato
tomato you know correct and you gotta
define them too correct sense of common
sense is different too true because i do
think like
our need for it
is heavily dependent on where you live
so for example like let's say um i
always bring up this this this story
about
in the border like southern arizona and
um new mexico there's these small towns
that don't have enough police so then
the cartels are really powerful yeah and
they come into the villages or the towns
and then they'll just be like all right
you guys could either let us just pass
through or we'll give you trouble and
then so a lot of the citizens there that
don't want that
they actually
become their own police force so then
they're like buying the ars and doing
all that stuff there was a whole like
vice documentary on it i was like damn
this is crazy this happened in america
so i'm like that or like let's say
you're a farmer
and you need the ar because like you
have a hell of coyotes and whatever or
like you just have
you know no police
five five ten miles from you right i was
like oh that might make sense but then
like in the city like la i don't know
yeah but why is it that we're the only
country with this issue
i think it's only developed no there's
uh
you're right
you're right
well that's how the country was founded
yeah we were the only ones that fought
part of our history yeah so it's hard to
take it away the the crazy thing that i
don't really get to is that the uh guns
were easier to access
prior to 1980. it was because there was
there was the assault rifle ban was in
the 1980s right uh you can mail order
guns you can buy guns easily all that
stuff you can you can carry it openly
but then the mass shooting things is our
generation like it's it's it's recently
so i'm like what happened in the u.s
culture that made it where the guns were
more easier to access but then now it's
harder to get but then the mass
shootings are more so you're saying we
should make them more easy to access yes
and then not just kidding i don't know
what the solution is i'm just making an
observation where that's weird it was
easier to get
but then people weren't sure
without guns they drive cars into crowds
yeah so it's like what happened in
france the mass violence happens
it's just like it's like our
generation's serial killer driving a car
into a crowd and then having a machine
gun
but the casualties are similar it's like
20 and 20. you know but do we have do
they have that many like driving cars in
the crowds versus the amount of mass
shootings that we have i'm asking
there's like
i think it's pretty similar there's a
mass shooting in the united states like
almost every day
you counting chicago i'm counting the
united states
there's a mass shooting every day
so that would be that's because it's
classified as three or more people i
think oh three or more so like then yeah
chicago would be because that could be
that could be that could be every day in
every country then if it's three or more
well i think obviously the internet
right you have the spread of information
a lot of these
current shooters are being led by
manifestos or causes
you know they're like new serial killers
man but before if you had to
is it the attention i think that's what
it is it's like you don't really hear
about like obviously like the 70s or
when like the ted bundys and the [ __ ]
night stalker like that was like what
was everybody's like oh our country is
going to [ __ ] this is this is crazy
there's all these crazy people at the
mass shooting i think this is our
version of this like our generation
today generation is like that's what
that is to me at least that's what i
think but instead of serial killers now
it's like people just mapping the [ __ ]
out it does seem like everyone's trying
to top each other you know what you mean
like in a weird way it's scary it's it's
pretty consistent though like this isn't
mass shootings uh this is gun violence
archive it says mass shootings but like
for example uh june 20th aka three days
ago uh new york eight injured one killed
june 20th four injured zero in staten
island south carolina june 19th two
injured two killed june 19th michigan
three injured one killed june 19 florida
five injured june 19th district of
columbia 301 killed so it's like
whether the master not by statistics of
three or more it's like there's
shootings
every day yeah yeah yeah yeah my um
friend when he was patrolling out here
in south central he said that every day
there's a call for uh some type of
shooting whether it's gang or domestic
every single day but the majority of
crimes that happen with a gun it's
actually a handgun it's not it's not ar
yeah the majority of it is handgun and
majority of that statistic of fatalities
come from suicide over over 60 70 it's
all [ __ ] it's a huge number most of
the death is suicide and majority is
also illegally obtained
so even if you add another law it's
they've already it's already not illegal
to kill someone and it's not legal to
have an illegal firearm so saying
it's illegal to own a gun
or add more loss to it it's not going to
do anything because gun-free zones
really didn't do anything which they
implemented no but like for example like
to go buy a gun there's no waiting
period depends on where here there is
yeah but not in texas yeah yeah no
nevada you don't have to but what if
that could have
deferred someone could have said like
obviously she said he said 2020s
hindsight but like if you're going to
get a gun for the right purpose whether
that be for protection or hunting or
collection yeah who cares waiting two
weeks is nothing yeah exactly i mean
that's that's my stance on it i think it
should be
[ __ ] hard as [ __ ] to get a gun yeah
but then i think once you can go through
it
because i think you should be [ __ ]
hard as [ __ ] to even have kids too i
don't think you just
i think there should be like a dmv of
children
to really have that like a very
difficult selection process but once you
get through it you could do whatever
well in japan i heard it's it's really
it's really strict and it's expensive
and they do mental wellness like
examinate examinations every year like
you have to renew it which i think makes
sense but they do everything so good
though the japanese but it doesn't it
like it's like yo if you have a device
that can kill another human being yeah
shouldn't you for your own safety and
the safety of others know how to use it
properly just anything's crazy talk to
you because even like like
what's god this is oh you're gonna take
my god
like it's that thing that goes like this
pendulum no the big [ __ ] ball that
smashes buildings wrecking balls oh the
wrecking ball like you can't just go out
and buy one cyrus you need a license i
think
you tried did you yeah he [ __ ] tried
he was like i can't [ __ ] buy a
wrecking ball what the [ __ ] i want to go
get a machine gun now i live in nevada
that's a really funny place goes through
construction site goes what's the lowest
you'll take for that
he goes to like an armstrong's garden yo
like anything that can
that can kill someone easily i think
should be
very hard to obtain that's what i do
and that's why like my mom shouldn't be
driving
my mom is an ar on the freeway but but a
car isn't designed a car isn't designed
to kill
lit but it's good
yeah of course it is this is what it is
so is this water bottle in the right
hands
the reason why it's so hard to implement
any of that stuff is because then who
becomes the regulator and who becomes a
gatekeeper and then that's where it goes
right back to oh well now you're trying
to restrict a certain population from
having access to the gun i think
everyone at this table would agree that
there should be
com like there should be there should
just be certain places have zero like
zero locks because they're zero because
their philosophy is there should be no
gatekeepers so then it really depends
then they're gonna deal with these
issues every single or higher likely
don't really have don't really even have
mass shootings i think like louisiana i
never really hear anything yeah they may
not and you could go and just buy the
store at once or there's not really good
news
i think it could it could also be
because the population is so low you
know and then like maybe the way yeah
like it's in their culture like everyone
goes hunting so then they see it as like
oh that's just like my fishing pole so
their mentality is completely different
right this is my weapon for destruction
yeah probably not hip-hop enough over
there
that's what it mainly is
it's too lame not enough freaking ozzy
osbourne music
and mortal kombat games
they're all too busy going to church and
praying everything politicians have
blamed
dude mortal kombat was the one mortal
kombat is the reason for mass shootings
first of all if you didn't have the
blood code nothing was bloody yeah it
was just spit i don't even remember what
it looked like nothing
you